-Welcome to "The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here. You're watching.
You made it. You all look good.
Well, guys, we had a great lead-in tonight.
We're following the January 6th hearing.
So...you guys ready for some comedy?
That's right. Earlier tonight, Congress held the first
public hearing on the January 6th attack,
and it aired in prime time across all major networks.
Yep. The footage is rough to get through.
Right after the hearing, I watched an episode
of "Dateline" just to lighten the mood.
Five minutes in, even Mike Pence was like, "I've had enough.
Let's see what's happening on 'RuPaul's Drag Race.'"
[ Laughter ]
Yep, they're saying each hearing could run anywhere
from 90 minutes to 2 1/2 hours.
Yeah, it's strange --
one minute you're watching the hearing,
the next, it's "American Ninja Warrior."
And so it's -- you're basically going from people scaling walls
to people...scaling walls.
Yeah, all the major networks are airing the hearings,
but Fox News isn't.
[ Audience ohs ]
Instead, they're showing reruns of January 6th
with a laugh track.
[ Laughter ]
I don't think that's -- They should --
That's right -- Tonight, NBC, CBS, ABC, MSNBC, and CNN
all showed the first hearing, but Fox News didn't.
Apparently, they didn't think it was newsworthy.
Let's see what they were focused on instead.
-Tonight on Fox News...
is the new Wendy's pink Frosty trying to turn your kids gay?
-Wow. That's...
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
They find that newsworthy.
Some more news out of Washington.
I read that President Biden has been dealing with
a rapid turnover of his staff.
Yeah, of course, the White House tried to spin it like,
"Hey, look at all the new jobs the President is creating."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, things are tough at the White House.
Today Biden was like, "Hey, Jill, can you believe
how many people are lea--
Jill? Jill?"
Well, this is fun.
Uber released their annual Lost and Found Index,
which reveals the items reported lost by passengers.
Glasses, phones, keys were some of the more common ones.
But get this -- five people left behind --
They left behind their dentures.
[ Audience groans ]
Apparently some people like to go for a ride because they love
the feel of the wind in their gums.
[ Laughter ]
Yep, people have left glasses, teeth,
and even a Bernie Sanders fanny pack.
In other words, Bernie Sanders lost a bunch of personal items.
[ Laughter ] Have you guys seen this?
There's a new trend on TikTok where people
are making "healthy Coke" by mixing
flavored sparkling water with balsamic vinegar.
[ Audience groans ]
Yeah, it really shows you the lengths Coke drinkers
will go to avoid Pepsi, don't you think?
Yeah, on a hot day, there's nothing more refreshing
than 32 ounces of salad dressing.
Some entertainment news.
The Hallmark Channel just announced
that their 2022 Christmas in July event
is going to premiere
three new original Hallmark Christmas movies.
[ Cheers and applause ] Yeah.
I love it.
-Wait. Christmas? in July?
Psssh. I don't have time for that.
-What are you talking about, Tariq?
There's always time for Hallmark Christmas movies,
no matter what time of year it is.
-No, Jimmy, there isn't.
I mean, you know how important my other career is to me.
-You mean your family's wooden toy-making business?
-Exactly!
And ever since I became CEO,
I've just been under a lot of pressure, you know?
There's just too many toys to sell!
Plus, you know I'm the chairman of my hometown's
big annual Nutcracker Festival,
and I still need to find a venue!
-Wow. I had no idea that you were under so much pressure.
-Yeah, well, I am.
And to top it off, Mayor Santa's expecting me
to make a big Christmas in July charity donation
at the kickoff -- party.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-The kickoff -- The kickoff party?
-Well, yeah! -Alright.
Well, Tariq, I think the answer might be closer than you think.
W-W-What's that on your bandstand?
♪♪
-It's a wooden nutcracker!
That's it!
We'll -- We'll hold the big annual
Nutcracker Festival kickoff party
at my family's wooden toy factory!
And then just donate all our extra toys to charity!
Jimmy, you just saved Christmas in July.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Will you marry me?
-What the [bleep]?
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
[ Steve laughing ]
-"Kickoff party."
-Yeah.
He didn't know how he was gonna do it at the kickoff.
-Yeah. -Party.
[ Laughter ]
Guys, I heard about a man who's suing American Airlines
after they mistakenly gave his name to police
in connection with a robbery at an airport shop
and he spent 17 days in jail.
Yeah.
Even worse, since going from American Airlines to prison
was an upgrade, he was also charged for it.
Hey. Listen to this.
A man in Florida was bitten by a 7-foot alligator
after mistaking it for a dog with a long leash.
[ Laughter ]
Unfortunately, he was bitten again when he tried calling 911
on a raccoon he thought was a phone, yeah.